si hace unas horas fue la cámara baja la
cámara de representantes con 219 votos a
favor y 209 en contra la que aprobó que
se acelerara a través de una resolución
el diseño de este plan de rescate
económico de giovanni en plan de 1900
millones de dólares que cobija entre
otras cosas puedes dar cheques de 1400
dólares a las familias de bajos ingresos
y de ingresos moderados como también
poner y ayudar con 160 mil millones de
dólares el plan para hacer frente a la
pandemia para además de avanzar con las
vacunas avanzar también con las pruebas
los republicanos habían sido invitados a
la casa blanca para negociar este plan
de rescate pero no hubo acuerdo
los republicanos alegan que les preocupa
mucho el déficit fiscal que los mil 900
millones de dólares
pueda significar para eeuu sin embargo
joe biden les dijo que pues sí aunque no
entendía por qué ahora les preocupaba el
tema del déficit
y hace cuatro años cuando hubo recortes
de impuestos por parte de donald trump
no les preocupó al déficit fiscal
gracias a cristóbal